Chevaliers, jamais fléchis, non jamais faiblis, pleure à tempête, somme de calme, toile qu'un beau ciel d'étoiles revancées.
Savez-vous les enfants que pendant des millénaires, l'homme a eu peur des montagnes.
Une peur irraisonnée de cet inconnu, de ces monts qui formaient une barrière infranchissable qui divisait l'Europe.
Et ceux qui s'aventuraient sur l'école étaient en empreinte d'une crainte superstitieuse.
Quelles créatures démoniaques pouvaient habiter ces lieux inhospitaliers ?
L'histoire de l'alpinisme commence véritablement en 1492.
1492, ça vous rappelle peut-être quelque chose.
Oui, tu as raison, mais là, ça se passe en France.
Un jour, le roi Charles VIII manda auprès de lui un de ses hommes de confiance, le capitaine Antoine Deville.
Je ne veux plus que ces bons inconnus nous enferment et que tous mes bons sujets tremblent devant eux.
C'est vous que j'ai choisi pour m'aider dans cette tâche, former une expédition et explorer ses sommets.
Ensuite, vous viendrez m'en rendre compte.
Un notaire royal va vous accompagner afin de consigner vos exploits.
Majesté.
Et voici l'expédition à pied d'oeuvre dans Loisan.
Vous constaterez que les tenues n'ont que très peu de rapport avec celles de nos alpinistes actuels.
Il y a l'art intérieur de pierre, car qui sait, on va peut-être trouver là des matériaux pour bâtir des églises.
Un fabricant d'échelle, car qui sait, on pourrait avoir besoin d'échelle pour grimper.
Et toutes sortes d'hommes d'art, d'artisans, de gendarmes pour parer au danger.
Et d'hommes de robe, car il fallait aussi se préserver des démons.
Et chose étonnante, quelques-uns de ces hommes vont parvenir au sommet du Mont Aiguille, à plus de 2000 mètres.
Capitaine est là-haut. Pour attester, vous devez aller le rejoindre.
Qui, moi ? Là-haut ?
Je peux vous prêter mon échelle ?
Je vais instrumenter ici.
En qualité de notaire du roi, j'atteste qu'en ce mois de juin 1492,
le capitaine Antoine de Villers est parvenu au sommet du Mont-Éduille,
dans le massif du Dauphiné, à plus de 2000 mètres d'altitude.
Voilà les enfants, c'est ainsi que veut inaugurer la conquête des cimes.
À mesure que passent les siècles, l'homme va monter de plus en plus haut
par des voies de plus en plus difficiles.
Cela n'ira pas sans drape.
Mais rien ne saurait arrêter l'homme intrépide.
Voici parti à la conquête de l'Himalaya, 1950.
Deux Français, Maurice Herzog et Louis Lachnal,
atteignent le sommet de l'Anapurna.
Le premier, 8000 mètres vaincu par l'homme.
Mais il reste encore à vaincre la plus haute des cimes, le mont Everest.
8 848 mètres, le toit du monde.
En 1953, une expédition britannique débarque à Katmandou, au Népal.
Signoké, je suis votre guide Sherpa.
Edmond Hillary, je suis alpiniste.
John Hunt, officier de l'armée britannique et chef de l'expédition.
Voici quelques-uns des porteurs qui nous accompagneront.
Nous ne partons que demain.
Vous avez le temps de visiter Katmandou.
venez. Qu'est-ce que c'est? Les cheveux d'un yéti, c'est très mauvais. C'est un vrai scalpe de yéti,
messieurs, un objet rarissime, vous savez, mais pour vous, pas cher parce que vous êtes des connaisseurs.
Regardez de plus près. Curieux, de vrais cheveux red et courts. J'ai vu quelque chose de ressemblant
à ça dans les dessins. Dites-moi, d'où vient ce scalpe? D'une vallée au pied de l'Himalaya,
près du monastère de Bédigne. C'est très rare, mais pour vous, j'ai fait un prix exceptionnel.
1000 roupies, c'est une aumône.
500, pas une de plus.
C'est impossible, monsieur. Les yétis sont extrêmement rares.
Ils ont presque disparu de nos jours.
Mais je veux bien pour vous de laisser à 900.
600.
Alors, arrêtez de discuter. Il nous faut absolument ce scalp.
Disons 800, c'est une pièce unique.
700.
750, c'est mon prix coûtant.
Les voilà.
Il faut que tu ailles chercher un autre scalp.
J'y vais tout de suite, père.
Je vais pouvoir lui faire une coupe.
Quelpe de yétis.
Ça, monsieur.
Les gens ont peur du Yeti.
Allez, venez, il faut nous préparer.
S'arrête ici. Maintenant, il faut marcher.
Quel paysage magnifique.
Oui, mais on n'a pas fini de marcher.
Il fait trop chaud.
Piqure est morte.
Passez un par un.
Attention, c'est étroit.
Du monde.
Personne ne l'a jamais atteint.
On a pourtant essayé.
Hélas, bien des hommes y sont morts.
Je suis bien content que nous soyons enfin arrivés.
Viens embaucher.
Hélas, son monastère.
Regardez.
Asseyez-vous, les enfants.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler de Shomolongma, la déesse mère des neiges.
Elle est vers le ciel, plus haut que toutes les autres montagnes.
Pures, le vent et les flocons de neige sont les seuls à pouvoir l'atteindre.
Aucun homme ne peut y accéder.
Pourquoi, maître ? Qu'est-ce qui nous empêche d'y aller sur cette montagne ?
Rien n'y vit, mon enfant. L'air y est rare, on ne peut respirer.
Il y en a à peine assez pour le vautour, la seule créature vivante qui puisse s'en approcher.
Oh, bien sûr, il y a le yéti.
C'est un saisissable créature cent fois plus forte que l'homme.
Et regarde, ce coffret se trouve la preuve irréfutable de son existence.
La preuve, oui.
Oh, faites-vous voir.
Ah non, non, non, non, non, non, je ne veux pas vous effrayer.
Quand vous serez grand, peut-être.
Si, si, montrez-nous, nous sommes grands.
Nous n'avons pas peur.
Non.
Tout ça, jamais vu du guédi.
Les gens du monastère l'ont vu.
Parfois, on entend son cri.
Parfois, j'en ai la vision.
Je vois des étrangers qui approchent.
Ils viennent pour conquérir nos montagnes, comme d'autres l'ont tenté avant eux.
Mais ceux-là vont peut-être réussir.
Vous pouvez aller les voir, mes enfants.
Nous sommes ici à 4000 mètres d'altitude.
Les gens du village sont mes amis, et nous allons pouvoir y établir un camp pour nous habituer à l'altitude.
Yang, c'est un de mes neveux.
Allez, venez, il faut que je vous présente au lama.
Attendez, mes amis.
Alors vous allez tenter d'escalader le Shomoluma, la montagne que vous appelez l'Everest.
Tant d'autres ont essayé avant vous, pourquoi essayer de nouveau ?
Pourquoi escalader cette montagne ?
Mais parce qu'elle est la plus haute de toutes.
Mes visions me disent que vous pouvez peut-être réussir,
mais attention, il y a le froid, le vent, la neige et puis surtout, le yéti.
Mais existe-t-il vraiment ?
Le yéti est moitié homme, moitié singe et grand comme ça.
Il se cache des hommes et il tue des animaux pour manger.
En avez-vous déjà vu ?
Jamais.
Mais en revanche, Gupta en a vu un l'année dernière tout près d'ici.
N'est-ce pas, Gupta ?
J'aime donc !
Croyez vraiment, vous, à ces histoires de Yeti?
Je crois qu'il ne faut pas prendre ça à la légère.
Je vais vous montrer quelque chose.
Croyez, ça, c'est une empreinte de pas relevé dans la neige.
À 6000 mètres d'altitude, vous avez vu la taille du pied
et le pouce est bizarrement tourné vers l'extérieur.
Ça, c'est la photographie d'un scalp comme celui qu'on a acheté.
Et ça, c'est un dessin fait par un savant d'après des témoignages.
Le Yeti mesurerait 2 mètres, alors vous comprenez qu'il fasse peur.
Je donnerais très cher pour en voir.
Et alors, à nous deux.
Ramenez une peau de yétis, ça ne serait pas si mal.
Mais dites, maestro, il existe réellement ce yéti ?
Ou bien des gens prétendent l'avoir aperçu sur les contreforts de l'Himalaya.
On l'appelle également l'abominable homme des neiges, mais qui sait ?
Oh, je vous en prie, maestro, il existe ou pas ?
Vous le savez sûrement.
Comptez-nous.
Vous verrez bien, mais n'oubliez pas,
si l'expédition est venue au Népal, c'est pour conquérir le mont Everest,
la plus haute montagne du monde, pas pour chercher le yéti.
Les hommes ont donc installé leur camp devant le monastère.
Là se prépare l'assaut, car l'Himalaya est dangereuse, très dangereuse, même plus encore que...
C'est le fameux yéti, hein, maestro ?
Moi, je reste quand même un peu sceptique.
Hansing, veux-tu demander à ton neveu dans quelles circonstances il a vu l'yéti ?
Je peux toujours essayer.
Hé, Gupta, tu mets en kérok.
Il dit qu'au printemps dernier, alors qu'il cueillait des murs, un yéti est sorti de la forêt en grognant.
Gupta a eu peur, il a lâché son panier et s'est enfui.
S'étant caché derrière un arbre, il a vu le yéti ramasser le panier et manger les murs.
Quand il a terminé, le yéti a secoué le panier vide, puis il l'a jeté par terre et il est retourné dans la forêt.
Demandez s'il veut se joindre à notre expédition.
Qu'est-ce que c'est Aron ?
Il veut bien si son copain Topki peut venir aussi.
Bien sûr, dis-leur que c'est d'accord.
Nous sommes au pied du glacier. On va établir notre camp de base ici à 5500 mètres, puis le camp 2, le camp 3, et ici le camp 4, à environ 6500 mètres.
Là, le camp 7, à 7500 mètres.
Et le camp 8, au-dessus de l'éperon, à 8000 mètres.
Là, on verra.
Des poils, regardez.
Le yéti, il est passé par ici.
Il faut jeter ça, ça porte malheur.
Encore le yéti ?
Si ça continue, je vais vraiment finir par y croire.
Donc, ces créatures existent.
Elles doivent vivre dans la forêt et s'aventurer jusqu'aux montagnes,
puisque cette empreinte a été faite dans la neige.
Merci.
Oh, c'est sûr qu'il existe, le yéti.
On verra, il faut dormir maintenant.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ? Il y a une tempête ?
Il part là !
On verra demain, c'est sur notre chemin.
À moindre toi.
Continue par là, vers les montagnes.
Plus loin, ils ont trop peur.
Ça ne fait rien, on continue sans eux.
Est-ce que tu viens, toi ?
Oui.
Merci.
Je viens aussi, moi, connect !
Tu es ici ?
Je vais aller jeter un coup d'œil par là.
Gupta, tu viens avec moi ?
Je ne vois rien.
Le soleil ne va pas tarder à se coucher, il faut rentrer.
Allez, viens, vite !
Son, et dire que nous l'avions pris pour l'amominable homme des neiges.
Va le remettre dans la grotte, sa mère ne doit pas être loin.
Son !
Chapébel, allez, on rentre.
Vous l'avez vu ?
Existe bien.
Le yéti, je ne sais pas, mais les ours de l'Himalaya, ils sont bien réels.
Ça, j'en suis certain, ça devrait aller.
On va essayer.
Vez un autre passage.
Pas le choix.
Il n'y a pas d'autre voie.
Faut passer.
Tu peux me remonter.
500 mètres, nous voilà au camp 4.
Il va falloir redescendre pour aller chercher du matériel et du ravitaillement.
Regardez !
Des provisions laissées par l'expédition suisse venue l'an dernier.
Chocolat.
Oh, qualité suisse est garantie.
Nous sommes à 7500 mètres.
Vous devez mettre les masses à oxygène.
Sinon, vous n'avez pas assez de force pour continuer.
Je crois qu'on peut y arriver.
700 mètres.
Pas du tout évident.
Faudra bien au moins trois heures pour y aller et deux pour assez d'oxygène.
Je suis un oiseau, il vaut mieux redescendre.
Complètement épuisé.
Bon à rien.
Redescend, à vous de jouer.
25 degrés Celsius.
Il y a tout juste assez d'oxygène.
Le temps s'est amélioré.
C'est maintenant ou jamais, mon vieux.
Alors on y va ?
On y va, vous.
Mais avant, on boit et on mange un peu.
Faut prendre des forces.
J'irai à 8500 mètres.
Oui, mais pour dormir, il faudra de l'oxygène et on n'en a pas.
On a besoin d'un litre par minute. J'espère qu'il en reste assez.
800 litres d'oxygène, 3 litres par minute, ça fait que nous en avons pour 4 heures et demie.
Ça devrait nous suffire, mais tout juste.
Parleur, va essayer.
Je t'assure, nous sommes 848 mètres, l'Everest.
De nos jours, on ne fait pas encore une promenade, le Mont-Everest, d'accord, mais croyez-moi.
L'homme trouvera toujours de nouveaux Himalayas à conquérir.
Eh oui !